simon liberati robosphère
alors simon liberati ce qui peut savoir
ses comptes à son nom sur google le mien
apparaît aussitôt regarder voilà avant
celui de votre femme simon veut dire
qu'on a des bons souvenirs tous les 200
2004 fait vieux ou journée une émission
avec des colonnes
des drapés y avait le lot il y avait
deux derniers vêtements il y avait
méline magnéto serge j'accueille
maintenant lui simon liberati
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les mêmes choses pour moi
mr
bah ça va aller il craque l'état paul
biya oui elle était parfait
ces cours
simon liberati votre premier roman
anthologie des apparitions chez
flammarion fait beaucoup parler je
dirais même que tout le monde en parle
c'est le cas de le dire voilà alors le
pitch je vais le faire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
je me souviens que les pompiers avec toi
qu'ils éliminent cigarettes et que vous
preniez feu donc c'était un risque à la
baisse a permis d'offrir à laurent
baffie évidemment une bonne note au
logis méline la même chose pour moi
extraordinaire vannes l'a d'ailleurs
tiens je vous ai rien proposé voulait
voir quelque chose moi je suis boit du
coca zéro ouais ça a changé parce que
j'entends patres ou non non pas pourquoi
c'est obstiné à dire ça j'étais drogué
j'avais bu enfin j'ai vraiment apprécié
et très drôle et très bien et c'est ce
que j'ai dit des choses très cohérente
et à chaque fois on coupe à ce moment là
d'accord vous commencez à et c'est moins
de trois jours est ce que quand même
vous vous continuez à prendre de la
cocaïne sur les capots des porsche avec
votre ami beigbeder serait pas une
porsche s'était je prends une voiture
genre moi je crois que c'est une porte
c'est fini ça j'imagine on s est fait un
mort ouais c'est fini tout ça c'est de
l'histoire c'est l'histoire ancienne
c'est vrai qu'après donc ils prennent de
la coke et beigbeder sur le capot d'une
bagnole ils ont été amenés chez les
flics et les voisins de cellule de
beigbeder crier beigbeder beigbeder de
nous dit 1000 euros et vous irez vous
étiez le dealer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors simon aujourd'hui vous êtes plus
besoin de boire pour surmonter votre
trac on va parler de votre livre
occident publié chez grasset c'est votre
dixième livre qui fait 496 pages tu
commentes on voit pas si souvent
carrément nettoyage
le narrateur s'appelle alain le roy
comme le héros du feu follet de pierre
drieu la rochelle dans sa jeunesse il a
été membre d'occident un groupe
d'extrême droite dix ans mais l'occident
dont il est question dans le livre de
simon c'est le monde occidental on
retrouve vos obsessions en fait dans ce
clip qui est très bien d'ailleurs l'art
la fois la déchéance pas vos grands vélo
bleu le personnage du livre c'est un
peintre qui acquit qui peint comme
comme pas un peu balthus une peinture
assez classique on va dire et qui se
trouve avoir une carrière assez modeste
mais assez agréable avec une maison de
campagne ou du travail et y rencontre
une jeune femme qui le
rend voûte un peu assez peu en fait et
qui le et qui le met en contact avec un
collectionneur et donc il ya une espèce
de mélange entre l'amour et la et
l'intérêt et l'histoire avance comme ça
et on part sur un roman un peu 18e avec
une intrigue un petit peu
à la liaison dangereuse et puis tout à
coup il ya une sorte de passion qui
s'empare du personnage et il part en
espagne et tombe amoureux d'une jeune
fille très jeune et schizophrène et
l'histoire se il ya une bascule et
l'histoire se dessine entre et pour
l'histoire
il n'y a pas vraiment de pic pour être
honnête il ya trois parties une première
partie qui raconte une histoire ensuite
une deuxième partie que c'était le
vortex qui est un truc je vais écrit il
ya très longtemps d'ailleurs ouais et
après il ya une troisième partie qui
reprend la narration c'est pas évident
alors saison voilà alors c'est pas
classe par le cas alors je te le dis moi
j'aimerais bien mais c'est un livre
assez compliqué en effet à résumer à la
à l'écran donc déjà vous vous rendez
bien compte qu'en disant ça mais
personne ne vous est pas le but si vous
voulez quand je viens pour vous parler
d'abord c'est le plaisir le plaisir
qu'on voit après devons revoir je ne
faisais pas vue depuis sept cette
émission 10 à 15 ans le temps des q1 et
après bon ben voilà le lait libre de
toute façon les résumés à agir dans une
émission de télévision c'est très
difficile de celui-là particulier dur
avant de le livrer oui les durant j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu évidemment non mais
je suis je pense que vous avez fait là
quand même sinon c'est quoi l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
c
est
trop
allez ce bail
qu'est-ce que je suis un comédien c'est
la seule personne que tous nos mines
chérir caméra
qu'est-ce qui nous a perdu raconte mehdi
yoplait première appelée à l'aide en
aval elle
dit nous comme il ya un nom il leur faut
des lunettes
qu'est ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
à simon liberati on va voir quel genre
d'écrivain vous aide à faire une
interview écrivain maudit
est ce que comme philippe sollers vous
écrivez toujours au stylo plume
absolument pas j'ai toujours écrit à
l'ordinateur ah ouais ouais est ce que
comme salinger vous avez finir par vous
retiré du monde bon c'est déjà fait un
jeu je vis dans un an oui vous avez
regardé
souvent table c'est vous qui le dites
non c'est à côté de la mairie c'est une
sève et c'est très joli bébé multaq
guitare y est vous vous êtes mortem
n'est pas morte elle sait que c'est une
abbaye c'est lui le baby qui reviennent
c'est une ruine un peu comme moi et
c'est trés c'est très joli adacore bien
est ce que comme michel houellebecq il
va péter non on préférait fumée ouais
c'est pas bien fumer des cigares à laval
st mais je fume pas de cigarette quand
je la dois soirée quand je ne me drogue
pas donc fut presque comme marguerite
duras vous vivez jusqu'à 6 litres
d'alcool par nuit j'ai pu y arriver mais
enfin je là comme j'ai pas encore faire
la ligue antialcoolique mais enfin j'ai
pas fini enfin ça m'est arrivé où il
s'est dit je pense que l'alcool
mentionne pas invraisemblable
ça s'appelle le pacte de varsovie
est ce que comme frédéric beigbeder pour
renifler
non je renifle pas et vous renifler plus
jamais on n'en parle jamais dans maariv
arrêté par la police ah oui non mais la
drogue oui donc ça c'est étiez cette
période là est fini si on le 30 ans pas
est ce que comme christine angot vous
prenez beaucoup de xanax non je produis
lexomil on les connaît une foire de
lexomil par soir alors on tue connaît ça
ça me permettait moi à l'époque à mes
débuts de pouvoir rentrer sur le plateau
sont trompés et touffah tu l'étais quand
même année moi j'avais le trac déjà la
ville d'arrivée je me dis oh [ __ ]
comment d'affaires
est ce que comme baudelaire vous êtes
accro au ch n'ont jamais j'ai toujours
détesté les choses qui transforme la
perception ah oui mais on voit bien
y'a drogue est drôle
il faut le dire aux enfants il ya drogue
enfants et on me dit la tâche surtout
dire aux enfants que nous bon on rigole
avec la drogue évidemment n'en prenaient
pas c'est dangereux vous défoncer pas
voilà c'est tout alors est ce que comme
rimbaud vous avez fumé de l'opium la wii
l'opium louis à l'opium c'est très
sympathique et surtout à la campagne et
en ville ça
est ce que comme romain gary booth de
tentes dépressif chronique pas du tout
n'ont jamais été des précédents mais
c'est vrai en fait on pourrait penser
que ceux des précédents mais ça se voit
se rend plus compte non non il est
vraiment un et comme il est
j'aime beaucoup est ce que comme
hemingway vous êtes de plus en plus
paranos peut arriver j'ai une femme très
paranoïaque comme moi je me suis moins
est ce que comme marie peu plus nouveau
volet qui a pas appelés
savez pense qu'il a pris
alors est ce que comme victor hugo que
j'étais obsédé sexuel non alors de moins
en moins à y qu'est ce qu'elle dit est
vain non mais ce poids là le rapport
d'un amoureux dans un couple a rien à
voir avec l'obsession sexuelle est ce
que comme ça vous aimez donner des
châtiments corporels
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux